is it bad that I don't know these off
Mahalo we're talking about magic numbers
today in many cryptographic algorithms
hash functions encryption suites and so
on you have the seemingly random
constants that appear because they're
necessary for various tasks and the
question is where do they come from who
thought up these numbers and why are
they important there are a lot of cases
where you want to start off with some
lots and ones jumbled up in some sense
before you then apply in quicken to do
it further that's the idea
so in sha-1 for example we have actually
some seemingly random magic number two
in there those things people know you
could look it up yet you could look it
up it's buried in the source code for
any of these implementations and it's in
the specification they're not secret
that's that's the idea they're not like
a secret key they're just public
knowledge so these numbers here are the
initial internal state variables for
sha-1 and I should add in the wrong
order by mistake so if you're going to
implement sha-1 don't use my computer
file video as your reference please
please to into an order but anyway the
internal state starts with these values
and then it proceeded by taking in the
message and jumbling itself up I'm going
to output a hash now the third question
is who came up with these numbers and do
we trust them right is there any way
that these numbers could be used to
actually make the algorithm weaker this
is the concept of nothing up my sleeve
numbers so think about a magician if
you're about to pull something out of a
sleeve they just show you at the
beginning there's nothing in there and
the kind of way of sort of going look
there wasn't anything in my sleeve
originally so it's not a trick in the
case of sha-1 these numbers were
produced by the NSA right but they've
taken steps to try and demonstrate that
they are actually just random nonsense
or predictable numbers from life rather
than very carefully crafted mathematical
numbers which allows us some kind of
backdoor so for example this one here is
you can see it's Oh one two three four
five six seven reversed right this one
eight nine ABCDEF so you can see they're
just counting up and counting back down
so they're basically counting now this
introduces some sort of seemingly random
noughts and ones to the initial state
but what it doesn't do is introduce
strange numbers that we don't trust
which is a very important thing in
cryptography like the same is true
of some other numbers used in charge
during the compression function which
are these ones here so these numbers are
two to the thirty times by root 2 root 3
root 5 and root 10 why we chose them in
some ways you know we don't know but you
can imagine but it would be quite hard
to produce some kind of clever
mathematical backdoor when you're just
using the square root of 2i because just
one number of everyone knows you know if
you depict these numbers at random so
they were in a sense it was unclear what
their origin was you maybe wouldn't
trust them as much so this actually has
precedent so the data encryption
standard was released many years ago now
developed by IBM and so we say adjusted
slightly by the NSA now at the time
there were some constants used in
certain internals inside DES which
looked a bit suspicious certainly it
wasn't so much that they were suspicious
is that no one knew where they come from
they'd just been defined by one of the
developers and just left there now as it
turns out they actually were left there
with a very good purpose they actually
made the algorithm stronger because it
was resistant to something called
differential cryptanalysis but at the
time when it seaming it seems random or
contrived you can't tell whether it's
because it's made it stronger or weaker
or it genuinely was random so in general
the cryptographic community is very
suspicious of numbers but don't have an
obvious reason there they're like I just
counted from one to ten right because
you can't produce a mathematical
backdoor based on counting because it's
too contrived if I was on stage and
dough did magic like but if I was on
stage and I said to you let's pick a
number at random I don't know
24 and then did some trick with it you
think well that's great but clearly 24
wasn't random
no it's that kind of principle you want
to have some way of demonstrating that
it was a truly random number or indeed
that in essence be the choice of your
number is important because everyone has
to use the same one it is going to be a
standard but in some ways what exact
number it was wasn't important that's
what you're trying to demonstrate so in
the case of Chartres they've just done
some counting
they've just produced a simple
mathematical formula that produces the
numbers such that people maybe have a
little bit more trust that's used it's
quite common to use 3 1 4 1 5 9 2 6 5 8
nine seven nine right because those are
the initial digits of pi but the point
is that if you use those numbers then
you can you can add some kind of you
know initialization vector for whatever
algorithm you're writing but I can't say
well you change that number to put a
back door in because that numbers PI I
can't change that number you know I
don't have that much power so but if I
picked let's say V be a millions in
second digit of pi and the one after
that and the one after that you say well
where did you get a million into from
you know why have you chosen that pot
pie so the point is that I've got to
have a due process and a clear reason
for picking this number where I've tried
to be very open and said look it's not
about the number I've just used it okay
that's the idea so I haven't got
anything up my sleeve after you Gary's
part well I can do better than that
because that's wrong oh yeah it's
3.14159265 three five eight nine seven
nine
so I've missed some out and some people
would have spotted that and they'll be
they'll be thinking words of me never
mind